has lost eight of his relatives
including his son they were kidnapped by
the elkanyat militia in the city of
taruna they controlled the city during
warlord Khalifa hafters failed 14 months
military campaign against Tripoli in
2019. for more than two years he's been
searching for his son he says the
government should do more
what happened afterhuna was a huge
Massacre over 1 000 people are missing
and they're only found around 200 to 300
bodies the rest are still missing
families want to know if their children
or siblings are dead or alive this is a
government responsibility When
government forces retook tohuna in 2020
authorities found Mass Graves evidence
pointed to the El kenyat militia that's
blacklisted by the U.S nearly 50 Mass
Graves have been found and 247 bodies on
Earth
those bodies are brought here to this
laboratory run by the search and
identification Authority for DNA tests
they've identified
160 bodies through DNA tests 137 of them
are from Mass graves in the city of
saruma with more than 350 people
registered as missing in taruna family
members say the government has been
slowed to identify the bodies of those
recovered but officials here say it's a
complicated and time-consuming process
bone samples are very difficult and
challenging to analyze because the
corpses were buried some of the bone
tissue has decayed due to environmental
conditions it takes time to get a good
DNA sample Abdul hakeem's brother Abu
Bakr a father of two was also kidnapped
by the elkanyat militia he says his
family suspected his brother had been
killed but still spent months looking
for him
I spent over a year with my brother
missing it's a bad feeling when you
don't know if your brother's alive or
dead when his body was identified
through DNA tests it hurts the hardest
part was telling my mother and his wife
but after burying him I was able to
relax
for many families in turuna there is no
choice but to wait and see if their
loved ones are among the dead for Abdul
Hakeem and his family there is grief but
finally an end to uncertainty well
trainer Al Jazeera Tripoli